un mot déjà sur le fait qu'Olivier du
soft a qualifié cette réforme dans Le
Parisien Aujourd'hui de réforme de
gauche c'est une réforme que vous
soutenez est-ce que vous nous faites
votre coming out de gauche aujourd'hui
comme il y a de gauche je pense d'abord
que le régime de retraite par
répartition il n'est ni de droite il est
ni de gauche il a été inventé aux sortir
de la Seconde Guerre pour réduire la
pauvreté des anciens de nos aînés et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui si moi je me bats
pour la réforme c'est pour sauver pour
faire en sorte notamment que pour les
jeunes générations il y a pas de
retraite à payer la leur et puis la
nôtre en même temps donc je crois que
dans cette réforme en tout cas au Sénat
on va s'attacher à y mettre des
marqueurs de droite que ce soit sur la
politique familiale que ce soit sur un
certain nombre de choses par exemple la
lutte contre la fraude comme l'article 2
quand on va y venir dans quelques
instants non je pense que c'est une
réforme qui enrichit avec le Sénat doit
être une réforme qui doit être soutenue
et tout à l'heure également à l'adoption
d'un amendement qui prévoit de réfléchir
à sur une dose de capitalisation dans
notre système par répartition ça aussi
c'est un marqueur de la droite est-ce
que vous pensez qu'il va bien pouvoir
rester dans le texte final je ne sais
pas mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
nous sommes d'abord et je le redis la
droite est pour la retraite par
répartition parce que tout simplement de
croyons au lien intergénérationnel qui
permet de matérialiser de concrétiser
que nous sommes dépendants des uns des
autres qu'il y a un lien entre nous
au-delà du temps au-delà des générations
ça c'est la première chose en revanche
comme la retraite par répartition est un
est une pardon un régime avec une
dimension démographique il faut
impérativement assurer le renouvellement
des règles générations ce qui n'est pas
le cas donc la retraite par
capitalisation viendrait enrichir on
aurait finalement j'ai utilisé de
substituer l'un à l'autre non je pense
que si on doit arriver un jour à la
capitalisation elle peut être solidaire
mais il y aura d'abord le premier étage
de la fusée c'est la répartition le
second étage le deuxième étage c'est la
retraite à points agir Carco la
complémentaire et il y aurait un
troisième étage qui serait une
capitalisation c'est solidaire pour ne
pas désavantager ceux qui n'ont pas de
moyens un mot sur le fait qu'Aurélien
Pradier et les députés LR qui sont
opposés à la réforme vont voir mercredi
Laurent Berger est-ce que pour vous
oriente a dit encore sa place chez elle
non mais il a comment dirais j'étais
débarqué de l'équipe dirigeante et de
son poste de numéro 2 par Éric aussi et
il a bien fait mais qu'il voit ce qu'il
veut voir les syndicalistes et les
autres voilà ça me gêne pas et en plus
j'en ai marre mais il peut rester
regarder sa carte je peux pas commenter
et passer mon temps à commenter tous les
faits les agissements de tous nos
sénateurs de tous nos députés de tous
nos élus locaux j'y perdrai mon temps je
crois non on va parler de cet article 2
que le Sénat s'apprête à discuter c'est
cet article sur l'index seniors la
droite veut en profiter pour instaurer
un CDI senior avec une exonération de
cotisation famille pour ce type de
contrat est-ce que vous avez chiffré
cette mesure
c'est une mesure difficile à chiffrer
puisque je peux vous dire c'est que
c'est une mesure qui rapportera de
l'argent le gouvernement fait une
mauvaise approche du gouvernement nous
dit oh là là cette mesure elle est
terrible elle va coûter 800 millions
d'euros cette mesure elle consiste je le
rappelle à remettre en situation
d'emploi des seigneurs qui sont au
chômage parce qu'on a un problème en
France on a un des taux les plus bas de
l'emploi du taux d'emploi des seniors
après 60 ans et comment repousse de deux
ans il faut impérativement avoir des
leviers pour remettre les seniors dans
l'emploi pour les garder dans l'emploi
et gouvernement nous propose un index
une statistique donc c'est pas
satisfaisant simplement ce que je veux
dire c'est que 1 le fameux coup du
gouvernement 800 millions est faux
puisque ça voudrait dire que tous les
seniors viennent aujourd'hui bénéficier
de cette mesure ce qui serait sans doute
pas le cas mais surtout surtout c'est
que nous ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
active des dépenses sociales passives
des indemnisations de chômage et on les
active pour que les gens rentrent dans
l'emploi et ça rapporte à chaque fois
que vous faites 100 000 seniors en
emploi ça rapporte un milliard dans les
caisses de l'État donc la mesure non
seulement elle est pas négative en terme
budgétaire elle est positive
[Musique]